today's speaker is Ron Smith the Damon
Wells professor of geophysics he's also
the director of the center of Earth
observation he's also a smart guy and he
won an award for teaching and I couldn't
find it I don't know what was the name
of that award I don't know either best
best best teacher Award of the
year that was it I'm sure yeah and uh he
is uh his focus is meteorology and
Regional climate and he does lots of
things uh one of the things he spends
times his time on is satellite remote
sensing of landscape landscape changes
and climate sensitivity which will feed
into his talk today and uh his current
projects are involved satellite analysis
of surface climate feedbacks which I
believe will feed into his talk today
and the title of this talk is surface
impacts and climate feedbacks in the
Texas drought
2011 thank
you okay so um this is work that is um
still in progress so any comments or
questions you have would be very
valuable as we try to wrap it
up we are uh for some time have been
interested in
various climate feedbacks and you
probably already know what I mean by
that but let me
try to put some flesh on this idea of a
climate
feedback um one well-known one snow albo
feedback is where you might have a
colder climate that would shift
precipitation from rain to
snow the snow lying on the on the ground
increases the albo of the earth which
reflects more sunlight which cools the
climate further that would be an example
of a positive climate feedback
a water vapor feedback would be uh you
warm the climate you evaporate more
water the warmer temperatures allow more
water vapor to be held in the atmosphere
water vapor is a greenhouse gas traps
more outgoing longwave radiation you
warm the climate further that's another
positive
feedback on a longer time scale uh a
carbon stocks feedback where a warmer
climate will drive Co 2 out of the
oceans maybe drive CO2 sequestered in
permafrost out of the land surface into
the atmosphere more CO2 more warming
warmer climate those are examples of
positive feedbacks where the feedback
loop increases the amplitude of the
climate anomaly the one I'll be talking
about today is this last one less welln
than the
others um well for one reason it can
work two ways and we're not sure which
way is going to dominate if you have a
um a heat wave or a
drought that's going to change the
nature of the vegetation on the
landscape most likely that's going to
turn uh say green grass to
Brown or a short grass to Barren soil in
either case that's kind of have an
influence on the albo generally when you
brown out the grass or when you replace
grass with bare soil you increase the
reflectivity of that surface that is to
say you increase the albo that by itself
would reflect more solar radiation and
would have a cooling effect that would
be a negative feedback on the other hand
uh when you have a heat or drought
wave you reduce the amount of water
available to
plants there's less evaporation now when
the earth receives radiation from the
Sun
it then partitions it
primarily into either sensible heat
going into the atmosphere that is just
warm air Rising convection radiation
carrying that heat quickly into the
atmosphere or
evaporation evaporating moisture at the
surface and carrying the water vapor
upwards but not directly heating the
atmosphere at least
locally the idea here is that in a
drought
you would change the partitioning
between sensible heat and latent heat
fluxes in favor of sensible heat
fluxes that would cause a warming of the
lower atmosphere that would be a
positive
feedback so we're going to be looking at
this last one today trying to decide
which one of these is
dominant these feedbacks can be
investigated I guess using any
change you can investigate any any
change in the Earth's surface it could
be the seasonal cycle it could be inter
anual variation one year wetter or drier
than the next it could be longer climate
change today we're going to be looking
mostly at interanal we're going to be
looking in in fact at a single event the
Texas drought of 2011 and see if we can
deduce what the nature of the climate
feedbacks were in that
event
so um this headline and many like
it you may recall from just about one
year ago this was all the rage in the
newspapers a year ago the Texas drought
and uh this is the one we'll be talking
about today and its
implications um surprisingly or perhaps
disturbingly I'm not going to try to
explain why this drought occurred in the
first place that's actually a very
difficult question I am going to point
to a couple of um possible attributions
over this new subject of trying to take
a climate or um meteorological event and
understand why it
happened is now called the science of of
attribution and it's very
new and and I must say I don't think
very welldeveloped we don't have good
tools uh the atmosphere in the ocean
have such Randomness to them that for
all we know a drought could occur just
by a chance superposition of a long
string of dry days it might not have an
actual detectable cause but I'll mention
these two so it has been known from
previous investigations
that um El Nino has an impact on certain
zones around the world in terms of their
climate for example when an nino
occurs it is generally thought to be um
warm in some
regions wet in others and the opposite
is true when you have
linia that is uh colder conditions in
the tropical Pacific Ocean then you get
the opposite side of this so let's look
at the time record of the Eno record
here
uh during 2011 period we had generally a
dominant linia cycle cold temperatures
in the tropical Pacific so you would
flip this and say that you might expect
to have uh a warm maybe even a dry
condition but not a wet condition in the
Texas area also that little region of
significant climate effect of alino is
not exactly covering Texas so uh I would
say one could perhaps draw an idea from
this diagram but not at all be certain
that that Texas drought from last year
was caused by the
linia another line of thought would be
to say well maybe this
is something to do with with global
warming maybe as the as the world
warms that there will be um local
climate anomalies that will be wet or
dry so this comes out of the
ipcc and it's soil moisture
anomalies this one for the middle of our
starting century and this one towards
the end under I don't know which
scenario it is but under one of the
global warming CO2 emission scenarios
and you will
notice a tendency for
drying in the Texas region on both the
short 50-year and the 100-year time
scale but again to attribute a
particular drought to this kind of a
global warming Trend I think is
exceedingly difficult at this stage our
knowledge simply isn't up to that up to
that challenge so that's not going to be
my focus today it's rather going to be
to look at local
feedbacks accept this as an accident or
an act of God whatever you prefer and
then look at the impacts on that region
of the world so this is it so just a
year ago if you went on to the Noah
website for Drought
monitoring you would see this
diagram and uh they've got a color code
there moderate severe extreme and
exceptional the brown color is coded to
mean exceptional by which they mean that
perhaps has never been a drought quite
this extensive in that region since
measurements began
there's a mix of brown and red colors in
there but no one would argue that that
wasn't if not the most uh the strongest
drought in Texas uh over the last
several decades at least one of the
strongest droughts remember this is a
cumulative measure so drought on this
scale is a combination of having below
average precipitation over an extended
period of time it might also be a
measure of soil moisture however which
roughly depends on the same things below
normal precipitation over an extended
period of time little did we know that
just a year ago that today we'd be
looking at a drought map like this this
was from just a week or so ago and uh we
had quite a remarkable drought in the
center of the country this year also so
these are coming now in seems like in
Rapid succession but they're all
different in fact um I read in a paper
recently that the um four of the five
four of the strongest droughts on record
have occurred just in the last decade
they would
be uh the Heatwave drought in um Western
Europe in
2003 uh the Russian the Eastern European
and Russian drought of
2010 um the Texas jot of 2011 and this
one of 2012 so this is almost now a
rapid fire
occurrences perhaps somewhat randomly
around the
globe of uh severe summertime Heats heat
and and
droughts by the way stop me if you have
questions I'd be happy to take your
questions Geor rank on that one of the
top five I think the Georgia that's what
I meant by the the Eastern European
Eastern European Russian drought yeah no
I'm thinking the one in geia oh no no
that that wouldn't rank on that scale no
that was too local and and not not
sufficiently
deep so we're going to be looking at
Texas and Texas is renowned for being a
big state and I want to remind you that
it is indeed a big state and not
uniform so um you have to remember if
when you look at a drought map like this
the drought may have covered most of the
state but actually there's more than one
climate zone as you come across Texas
for example there's the Cen the famous
Cen climate scheme is there and it shows
a rather major break between West Texas
and Central and East Texas and further
when you look at the um Forest cover for
the United States which is also a
reflection of regional
climats you have forests in East Texas
but not in Central and West Texas so
there's a climate zone across the state
and we're going to use that to ad our
advantage because we're going to be able
to use that single
event the Texas jart of 2011 to look at
climate impacts in three different
climate zones all within the state of
Texas um a bit of precept data just to
set the stage so we've looked at these
three regions here um in Texas
West Texas Central Texas and Eastern
Texas here's the rainfall data uh for
West Texas four data sets are shown
um let's see the black symbols are the
so-called reanalysis data um for uh for
that particular region of
Texas for a normal
year the red is the same reanalysis data
for the year
2011 you see the there really was a
strong precipitation deficit in that
year just to check that we've taken the
weather stations shown here in the dots
and average them together in other words
we've done our own little uh
climatological analysis and those are
the bar graphs but those two agree
pretty well so no matter whether we do
the data or we let the national um
Weather Service do the data analysis we
get about the same picture for for that
and that is to say that at least in the
first eight months of the year the
precipitation was only about 15% of the
normal for that part of the world the
same thing could be said for Center and
East Texas perhaps not as dry as West
Texas relatively speaking but still uh
one4 to 13d the precipitation so an
extremely strong D drought in all three
of these climate
zones across Texas
now the focus the methodology today is
primarily a space based methodology
we're going to be looking at Texas by
using orbiting environmental satellites
and these are the two we're going to be
using Lancet on the left the motor
sensor on the terce satellite on the
right um these two have very different
characteristics and we've used them in
different ways to complement each
other lat um
has a very high resolution
spatially 30 meter pixel sizes it can
resolve you know individual agricultural
fields on the surface of the Earth but
it has a 16-day return time it only
takes a look at a certain place on the
Earth every 16 days and then with cloud
cover that turns into more like a six
month or a four Monon return time you
only get a look you come over every 16
days but then it's going to be cloudy
and then cloudy and then maybe the third
time you'll get a good view of the
surface so that's the
advantage but the disadvantage of the
LSAT system the motor system uh has a
much broader field of
view um the uh pixel size is a kilometer
we're not able to resolve small objects
but it gets a daily image clouds are a
problem there too but it means you
probably get a good look at that surface
every
8 to 10 to 12 Days something like that
at the worst and so you get pretty good
spatial coverage even in spite of the
um of the clouds so we're going to be
trying to use these two in a
complimentary fashion here's lanat for
example it's in near polar orbit takes
99 minutes to go around the earth has a
sense around it that measures light
received at the satellite in several
different wavelengths three bands in the
visible
one in the near infrared two in the mid
infrared and one out there in the
thermal infrared we're going to be
especially using these two well we're
going to be using all of these and this
one as
well I should say modus has a similar
array of sensors with even even more
wavelengths
available so to um to come down to the
core of it we're going to be using
satellite
to detect three different quantities
that'll tell us something about the
nature of the Earth's surface first is
the normalized difference vegetation
index ndvi for short which is a measure
of the density of green vegetation I'll
show you diagram for how this is done it
basically uses the contrast between how
red light reflects from the surface and
how near infrared light reflects from
the surface the second will will be albo
I mentioned it earlier it's the net
reflectivity of sunlight from the
Earth's surface so it's a reflectivity
weighted with the um emission spectrum
for the sun's surface so you it's
weighted with the radiation coming from
the from the Sun and the last is the
land surface temperature so-called LST
I'll be using that acronym over and over
again it's
basically measured by um determining the
intensity of thermal infrared radiation
reaching the satellite and then
inverting the plank function to find the
temperature of the object that is
radiating um that that
energy so um just a bit more on the
ndvi here's a typical plot of how two
objects actually three objects reflect
radiation there's wavelength on this
scale in microns and the reflectiv ity
in percent on the Y AIS uh soils look
like this their reflectivity gradually
increases with wavelength but the most
remarkable is green vegetation which is
fairly dark by the way the visible
spectrum goes from4 to 7 microns so the
human eye is sensitive right there and
vegetation is generally dark to our eyes
but just beyond the visible right at 7
the reflectivity jumps up to to a much
larger value so forests and grass and so
on is actually quite a strong reflector
at wavelengths just beyond the human eye
and we'll use the
contrast between the near the near IR
reflectivity there and the red
reflectivity there to build uh the ndvi
it's um green minus red over green plus
red and that's the ndvi now this has
been used for 30 years or more these are
typical values for ndvi for example
dense vegetation reflects only 10% of
the red but half of the near IR you put
that into the formula you get an ndvi of
0.7
roughly uh dry bare soil you saw the
numbers that's a lower ndvi clouds
they're very bright but they reflect
both types of radiation roughly equally
therefore they've got an ndvi close to
zero snow and ice and water have
negative ndvis because they actually
reflect more in the viz than they do in
the
N so here's a plot for all of
Texas of the modus
derived
ndvi for about a 11year
period um the plus or minus one Sigma
curves here refer to the spatial
variation across the state so there's
quite a wide variation about the mean
but let's look at the mean for a second
first of all what you see mostly is the
annual
cycle lower in the winter higher in the
summer but in some years with a multiple
maximum two
Maxes I'm not sure I would say that
there's a third one there but in many
years you see elements of a double ndvi
Max due to different crops different
land surfaces it's not a simple smooth
curve even when averaged over the whole
state you see a little bit of this
double
pulse I won't be saying much more about
that I just want to give you a sense of
the quality of the data and what we can
detect from it but you might want to
also notice the very last Peak here
which is the year the summer of 2011
that's the drought that we'll be talking
about today A reduced vegetation
coverage connected with that uh reduced
precipitation we can do the same thing
for LST that's the um the skin
temperature of its radiative it's
radiative temperature it's often called
the temperature at which it radiates and
once again you see the annual cycle
winter to summer winter to summer and
then in the last year the drought year
you see a hotter surface than was ever
present in the decade before giving us
more clues that the signal we're looking
for is probably there in this modus data
so this is the questions we want to ask
from it then can we detect and quantify
the impact of the drought on land
surface using this space uh spaceborn
technology uh did these changes modify
the surface heat budget of the surface
um do they produce a positive or A
negative climate feedback and which land
covers which particular land cover types
contribute the greatest change in that
climate
feedback so the methods I'll be using
are these we've already talked about the
first one I've identified three
different climate zones across Texas to
give us three different U um possible
responses we're going to use the modus
data to derive time series for ndvi albo
and LST oh and by the way from that
we're going to do some computations of
the Heat budget terms as well to Quant
quantify this in a more useful way we're
going to use lanat which has the smaller
pixel size to zoom in and be able to
look at these changes by land cover
type and finally we're going to use land
set to create what we call change images
where we can see more much more directly
the role of the different land surface
Types on the climate
response so here's part of Texas uh the
coastline is down here Oklahoma's
there um the blue areas are ones where
we summed over to get modus
averages of LST ndvi and um and
albo the orange uh squares were as close
as we could come to that for our landat
analysis for some technical reasons we
couldn't get them to exactly overlay
mostly having to do with cloud
cover and then the little purple Square
there is where we were able to zoom in
using lanet and I'll show you those at
the end of the talk you'll actually be
able to resolve features on the ground
and see what their contribution was to
the climate
feedbacks so we're going to start with a
motus
analysis this is stuff that DEA did as
part of her PhD
thesis um and there are nine panels here
so the ones on the left are for West
Texas Central Texas and East Texas and
then you've got the three variables that
we're deducing from space land surface
temperature um Elbo and the vegetation
index
ndvi the blue are the average of the 10
preceding
years and there's some variability from
from year to
year and so to get some sense of that
we've put a one standard deviation a one
Sigma plus or minus on there in the blue
dash curve and then the Red Data is the
U drought year of
2011 so let's first of all go across and
look at the top panel first of all what
you're seeing here primarily is the
seasonal cycle in temperature the land
is colder in the winter warmer in the
summer um that amplitude is a little bit
greater in West Texas than it is in East
Texas and in the 2011 drought year we
see a rather substantial extra
warming a little bit hard to read the
scale but that's approaching 10° Celsius
for an overheat on the surface in that
particular year it's that large also
maybe even a little larger in Central
Texas but generally smaller in East
Texas with the exception of late August
where we had that U bump there by the
way this time scale is simply day of the
year 1 to
365 the albo is
here normal years are in blue the
drought year is in red and as we
expected um the drought year the surface
got a little bit brighter it's now
reflecting a little more radiation check
the scale out though it's not a huge
amount the the uh Alida went from about
02 to maybe2 two significant but not
huge in the albo variation and down here
in ndvi the blue is the normal the red
is the drought year a rather dramatic
difference especially later in the year
when the drought has had more impact on
reducing soil
moisture now let's just look at these
all together then so West Center and and
East I would say overall probably the
center of the state has the biggest
impact although it's albo impact was
delayed until the second half of the
year it's uh it's certainly larger than
the East maybe comparable with the west
but down here the albo drop is large all
the way across and as I indicated the
temperature is has the largest anomaly
in Central Texas smaller anomalies in
Eastern
Texas now from that data we're able to
do some rough estimates of the terms in
the heat budget
equation and I want to uh talk about
those here part of this format is the
same West Central and East Texas but now
what's plotted is the net radiation
reaching the
surface the sensible heat which is the
convective and conductive heat into the
atmosphere and the latent heat which is
a measure of evaporation from the
Earth's surface what we do is deduce
this from the satellite
data this from a combination of
satellite data and surface data and then
this is computed as as a just to fill
out the budget in other words we have to
conserve energy so that's computed at
the end now first of all notice the
difference across the state um in West
Texas you generally have less net radi
well you see the seasonal cycle of
course that's due to this change in the
sun angle uh during the year but you see
a difference from uh east to west across
the state that's due to um in part the
fact that West Texas has a higher
albo did I show you that yes look at the
albo going across the state so more
sunlight is reflected in the west and
less in the East
typically and that's why there's
generally less net net radiation in the
west than there is in the east now we
split that apart and see how it
partitions between latent heat and
sensible
heat and um for example starting in the
west almost 400 watts per square per
square meter goes into sensible heat
because it's a very dry landscape in in
a typical year only about 50 watts per
square C centimeter per square meter
goes into latent heat contrast that with
East
Texas about 700 watts per square meter
of net
radiation very little of that goes into
sensible heat almost all of that goes
into
evaporation so you have a very big swing
in the way that the land surface
balances its energy budget between East
and West Texas let's now look at the
anomalies for
2011 let me just focus on Central Texas
there's too much to talk about in all of
these okay so by the time you get to
August you're seeing quite a reduction
in net
radiation in Central Texas compared to a
normal Year and that is primarily due to
that increased albo you're reflecting
more of the sun's
radiation um so there's less radiation
to be
partitioned between sensible and latent
heat but let's see how that partitioning
is done in spite of the fact that
there's less radiation to be partitioned
the sensible heat actually climbs
there's more heat conducted and
convected into the atmosphere and the um
latent heat drops nearly to zero very
little evaporation there that partly
answers the question that I posed in the
very beginning of the talk about what
kind of feedback we're going to get here
there is going to be an albo effect it's
going to reflect more of the sun's
radiation but that is overwhelmed by a
shift in the
partitioning of how that net radiation
goes into heating the atmosphere I want
to um emphasize
that was there a question yeah actually
go back to the previous one yeah just
wondering if the um in the middle the
red the red graphs are they just scale
versions of the of the top one they more
or less
follow go the top top right well that's
right I because this data is partly used
to compute that so there is a a feed
through from this data into that data no
doubt yeah
yep so that idea that basic idea is
summarized here I've looked I've
summarized just for Central Texas late
summer just simplifying all that down to
this one little region this one little
time got two diagrams this is the normal
year that is to say the average of the
10 years preceding 2011 and this is 2011
now uh the red arrow is the net
radiation that's the
sunlight that is absorbed there's also
some long wave radiation in that but I'm
going to ignore that for the time being
it includes it but I'm not going to talk
about this basically is the sunlight
absorbed and that is reduced in the
drought year because the surface has a
higher
albo now this energy gets partitioned
notice the addition here right those add
to that this adds to that this energy
has to be put back into the atmosphere
in a normal year that's done mostly by
latent heat by evaporating
moisture um and the sensible heat is
somewhat smaller important but smaller
in the drought year however that's
primarily done by sensible heat uh so in
spite of the fact that there's less net
radiation to be partitioned there's
actually more sensible heat in other
words the surface is heating the
atmosphere directly more
in this case than it would be in a
normal
year that tells us how those two
feedbacks work the partitioning is more
important than the
albo so uh to summarize this part of the
talk um these three Texas regions have
significantly different surface
properties and heat budgets the drought
year had lower ndvi higher higher albo
and higher land surface temperatures the
the drought year had lower net radiation
due to a higher albo but higher sensible
heat flux that is to say more warming of
the lower
atmosphere and Texas in the center felt
the largest impact of that the sensible
heat was up by a rather amazing 150
watts per square meter that's a huge
change in that surface heat flux term
sensible heat flux
term now um we also looked we zoomed in
with with the
landat to look at how the different land
cover types
responded and uh this shows the summary
for West Texas again it's the same three
variables you should have these
memorized by now land surface
temperature albo and the vegetation
index now this one's a little bit more
complicated because we did it both for
July and for August so you actually see
four bars here a norm normal July and
then July of the drought year and then
in normal August and in August of the
drought year in every case especially in
the July data you see the LST jumps way
up except where you have water surface
water responds in a very different way
than a dry land surface would the albo
jumps up as well in every case more in
some land cover types than others and
the ndvi drops
in each case there's a drop going to the
drought year again more in some regions
than others and you get a similar
contrast in regions when you look at
Central Texas here we only did it for
August so you just compare August of a
normal year August of a drought year
notice that except for the water all of
these are responding in a qualitatively
similar way there's not a great deal of
difference I'm going to be pointing out
some differences that I think are
important here but you don't see it much
in these diagrams perhaps for example
the albo goes up a little bit more for
pasture
land or um but you know the shrub land
it jumps up quite a bit as well not as
much in the forest not as much in the
urban you have to look at all these
together to get some kind of a overall
summary and then for East
Texas this is is the wetter part of the
state um there again we've only done it
for August so you find that um the
forests are hotter they haven't changed
their ndvi I'm sorry I haven't changed
their albo and they've dropped their
ndvi just slightly here the biggest
impact seems to be in pasture land you
see it there in the
ndvi and you see it there in the LST
that's heated up more than these other
areas something about C land with it
shallow rooted
grasses um makes it respond more
strongly to the
um to the climate change that year so um
summarizing those all land cover types
were impacted by the drought except the
water
class somewhat of a difference from Zone
to Zone in West Texas shrubland and
rainfed agriculture had the biggest
response Central Texas shrand and
pasture East Texas General it was the
pastures that responded most
strongly we're going to try to
illustrate that
now what I've got here are some lat
zooms into a small region that Dimension
is only about 11 kilometers so we've
really zoomed way into a small area and
I've got four
Images two
there and then this two that go go along
with it let me run through that so on
the left for a small part in West
Texas you've got a u what's called a
false color
image we use reflective bands beyond
what the human eye can see to create a
colored image that conveys some
information about that scene uh for
example band seven in the midir has been
assigned to the red
gun band four which is the near infrared
is assigned to the green gun and band
two uh which is in the visible is
assigned to the blue gun so this is not
true color but it gives us more
information than a regular um visual
color image
wood uh and over here by the way is the
is the terrain there's a scale here this
is about a plateau about 900 m above sea
level down here at it's about 150 M
lower than that with quite an Abrupt
terrain break here in fact you can see
that reflected there in the nature of
the vegetation in this part of
Texas well um what do you
see the black dots are
ponds mostly farming ponds used to store
water the green circles are of course
Center pivot irrigation
which is the most uh cost effective way
of irrigation in West
Texas the uh rectangular Fields you see
how they have got nice rectangular
outlines those are agricultural fields
that are in general not irrigated that's
generally rainfed agriculture in those
areas and then down here you have some
natural areas it's rugged shrub and
grasslands down in the southern part of
the image so we've got a nice mixture of
land cover types and we can see how the
drought impacted those different land
cover types and that's what shows up
here so on the left you've got the
change in ndvi basically you just
subtract two images you take the ndvi in
2011 subtract the normal Year from it
and the scale is down here hard to read
but zero is there positive changes are
red negative changes are blue and then
on into
purple so um this natural range
land probably um I could should call it
shrub and grass land has had a slight
drop in its
ndvi it's a dry year the natural grasses
probably didn't come out that year let's
look at the human altered landscape
which is all of
this the uh Center pivot irrigation
um some of it has a small change some of
it has a large change depending on
whether they put water on the field that
year the rainfed agriculture is
uniformly well not uniformly because it
still varies but everywhere is strongly
negative in other words there's been a
big drop in rainfed
agriculture uh everywhere in this scene
due to the drought corresponding to that
are how how the land surface
temperatures have
changed the uh LST scale here these are
all positive values that's 3.6 going on
up to I think 18 degrees
celus there are some areas large areas
here up in the rainfed agriculture that
had a land surface uh warming as large
as 15 to 18° C there were other regions
where it barely changed at all
and of course you recognize that as some
of those Center pivot areas that were
irrigated in the drought year in spite
of the fact that there wasn't as much
irrigation water available those farmers
were able to get water to put on their
Center pivot irrigation and therefore
they've got a smaller response so you're
seeing at least those three things right
the natural landscape the rainfed
Agriculture and the irrigated uh
agriculture responding differently to
the drug
stop me if you have questions on these
these are hard to look at if I if you're
seeing them for the first
time any questions
here let's go on to Central Texas a very
different landscape terrain is on the
right you see of kind of kind of an
erosion pattern with higher terrain here
but um a series of uh small streams
merging to form a river going off to the
Northeast you see that feature here in
the reflected light as well again it's a
RGB a false color
composite there's a variety of
vegetation patterns here but the most
remarkable thing you would agree is this
dendritic pattern of the streams and the
rivers but they're dry most of the year
they're dry when this image was taken
certainly and that land is very often
grass
covered sometimes even grazed in the
summer time but not this year it's quite
Barren this year you see it has a bright
white reflective surface because it
doesn't have its normal repairi and
vegetation along those River
courses let's see if that's reflected in
um our ndvi change or in the land
surface temperature
change now here's the ndvi change Zero
is way up there so these are all
negative so there's been a big drop in
the vegetation index but the strongest
are these blue
areas let me flip back and forth and
we'll see where those blue areas
are those are those reparan zones those
zones that had water this is a fairly
dry climate but those uh River courses
have water in the summertime in them but
not in the drought year and therefore
the vegetation decreases rapidly there
now let's look at the LST and see if
that responds in a similar way it does
it's right where you see the maximum
drop in the ndvi that you see the
maximum rise in the temperature so less
evaporation because the vegetation and
the water is not there allows that
surface temperature to
rise after receiving heat from the
Sun and we're going to do one last and
that's East Texas again a very different
landscape the um the purple is
pasture the uh green is
wetlands and the forests of East
Texas the so-called piny Woods of East
Texas are these darker areas up
here and here is the the terrain you can
see that Wetlands is in fact
following um a water course down here
flow is from Northwest to Southeast
let's see how these land cover types
pasture wetlands and um Forest responded
to the climate
change on the left is the nvi
drop and it looks to me like the biggest
nvi drop is in this
region that's the pasture not every
pasture but generally the pasture land
responds more strongly
to drought in terms of um dropping its
vegetation and with
temperature some of the
highest uh increases in temperature are
in this region and also a little bit up
into this region let's see what that was
up
there see if that was also pasture yeah
I think it I think it was yeah so um
there we've zoomed in and used the power
of digital image processing to actually
seek these uh
changes as a function of land use or if
you if you prefer land cover type they
each respond and then the region is
going to respond in total as a weighted
sum of these different land cover types
so for example in East Texas where you
have uh something like 33%
forests they've got a a smaller
response um that's going to give a lower
response to the whole region as well I
think we can go on to summarize now and
then we'll leave some time for questions
so just to repeat the methodology was to
divide it up into three different
climate zones to get more information
use a modus time series of these three
satellite derived quantities go on
beyond that to compute some estimates of
heat budget term and then use land to
zoom in and see what the different land
cover types are doing here's what we
conclude the 2011 Texas drought indeed
had a significant signature we can see
it easily from space it's more than one
standard deviation above the normal
year-to-year
variation all the land cover types
except for water showed a similar trends
that is decreasing ndvi increasing albo
and an increasing LST but they differed
in the magnitude of the response
depending on the land cover type uh the
signature differed somewhat between West
Central and East Texas depending on the
dominant land cover type East Texas had
the smallest change as it's dominated by
forests and wetlands both of which were
rather um resilient resistant to change
under the impact of the drought dryland
farming in pasture land makes the
biggest
contribution note that these are both
human altered
Landscapes so what we found is that when
you go into an area and you you take an
area that was forest or you take an area
that was dry shrub
grassland and convert it
to um farming or pasture or grazing you
make it more sensitive to Drought not to
Sur surprising right you're replacing it
with um um annual grasses for example
with shallow
roots which means that when you get that
drought coming along it's going to be
much more impacted than by a tree for
example that has deeper roots or a a
Desert Shrub that while they look pretty
small at the surface they too have quite
an impressive root system making them by
their own Evolution more resistant to
this kind of drought
um and finally that question about which
feedback dominates we have a clear
answer to that while the net radiation
decreased due to the increased albo the
sensible heat flux increased uh due to
the decreased evaporation and that by
the way is a a feedback process that
also acts to link heat waves and
droughts in other words a drought if you
don't already have the heat you'll get
it by that added sensor ible heat when
you've shifted the partitioning of
latent heat and switched that over to
sensible heat and I think I'll end there
thank
you happy to take
questions yeah Trudy so uh I was
thinking about another feedback uh you
said that the net radiation at the
surface decreased because of the
increase
ofo and that therefore but there was a
different difference in the partitioning
between late that's right yeah but as
you have a reduction in the late and
heat you could have a feedback in terms
of cloudiness right so you could have
less cloudiness and therefore you
actually increase the net radiation in
the in the whole sky right I think
that's a very important one it's missing
from this analysis though because all
the satellite data for reasons you can
imagine are done on clear sky days right
you can only view so this is is the
biased what I've given you here has just
the bias that you've pointed out there
these are clear sky analyses and
therefore they don't capture the effect
of a change in
cloudiness due to that change in land
cover which I think is a probably a
significant contribution but I don't I
can't capture it here because we're
trying to look at the Earth from space
that's a problem good
point yeah SE
blue and
reds you look at West Tas it looks like
there's a big shift in November
December back to here or well no where
you had blue oh yeah okay right right
right right yeah like um these for
example at for example wests like it's
going or or sorry this is the other one
let me get the one before yeah yeah be
was here yeah yeah exactly so there's
this increase in November in normal a
huge
increase during the Dr what's going on
there um you're talking about that one
so that's at the end of the drought in
the uh if you look back at these uh
rainfall diagrams the drought actually
ended in November
there
you see you begin to get some U rainfall
near the end of the season it's a dry
November but it's a fairly wet October
and then December is up again so these
curves come closer together at the end
of the year but your second point was
um
well the red is the normal year it's
flat the they be is roughly flat and
then increases a bit towards the end of
the year I don't know the reason for
that little increase but generally it's
pretty flat across the seasons in a in a
normal year we could look back Matt we
could look back and try to figure out
why why you get that increase there but
I don't I don't know the answer to
that yeah
um not likely but but possible
yeah there is there is some elevation
there um it's an elevation it's about 8
or 9 900 meters above sea level so it's
possible you can get some snowfall in
the in the latter part of the
year